business suit-wearing babies the world's
cutest puppies and ninja toddlers are
just some of the things you'll find in
DreamWorks new animated movie the boss
baby yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan
here and in this video I'm going to be
revealing some cool behind-the-scenes
secrets and fun facts about the boss
baby movie before we kick off I'm giving
away this fantastic hardback book from
Titan called the art of the boss baby
which has loads of sketches storyboards
and info on the movie all you need to do
for a chance to win a copy is subscribe
and leave a comment about the boss baby
movie on this video and for bonus ways
to end to check out the gleam link in
the video description below ok let's get
stuck into some secrets and fun facts
about the boss baby movie to make sure
they captured the right facial
expressions for boss baby the movies
animators spent many hours online
watching videos of babies especially
ones that caught a baby's first reaction
to something for example a new flavor of
food or seeing a pet for the first time
likewise when it came to creating the
world's cutest dog the forever puppy the
animators found their inspiration by
watching tons of online videos of super
cute puppies and one of the movie's
animators Dan Wagner also brought in his
rescue puppies for a visit to the studio
to further inspire his fellow animators
during their work on early versions of
the movie the filmmakers planned to have
boss babies special mission team of
Stacey Jimbo and the triplets voiced by
adult actors however it soon occurred to
them it'll be much funnier if they cast
child actors instead so they could play
up the fact that although the team is
supposed to be there to help boss baby
they actually often hinder and annoy him
because they act and sound more like
babies than grown-ups instead of aiming
for a photorealistic look that's now
possible in animation thanks to advances
in technology the boss baby director Tom
McGrath wanted his movie to have a
graphic stylized aesthetic and for his
characters to be flexible and fleshing
so he drew inspiration from the handmade
look of the Golden Age of animation
which he and many of his crew grew up
with for example the movie's elastic
visual style owes a lot to classic
Looney Tunes and Merrie Melodies
cartoons and the work of legendary
animators and directors such as Tex
Avery Chuck Jones for his Freeling and
Bob Clampett who brought to life stacks
of iconic characters including Bugs
Bunny Daffy Duck Porky
he Sylvester the cat and roadrunner
indeed Alec Baldwin who voices boss baby
says he learned a lot about playing
tough demanding characters by watching
Looney Tunes cartoons as a child
particularly the way voice actor Mel
Blanc played characters like Foghorn
Leghorn with such Swagger and authority
various Disney animated features also
influenced the boss baby team especially
the charming nostalgia of the 1950s
classic lady in the [ __ ] and the
beautiful creations of artist Murray
blur who worked on films such as Peter
Pan Alice in Wonderland and Cinderella
although the boss baby movie was
inspired by Marla Frazee's best-selling
picture book it also draws heavily on
the personal experiences of the
filmmakers an artists who often swap
stories with each other about their own
families during the production for
example Tim stuffed toy lamb-lamb was
based on a much-loved toy lamb that
belonged to the daughter of the movie
screenwriter Michael McCullers and it
was directed Tom McGrath who added an
older brother and the idea of sibling
rivalry to the movies story as it
reminded him of his own childhood where
he was the younger brother or boss baby
and his family
so for mcgrath the film became a loving
amage to his older brother originally
miles Bakshi who plays Tim was hired
just to record a temporary voice track
while the filmmakers were working on
their various storyboard ideas but they
thought his performance was so good that
they decided to cast him in the final
movie and like his character Tim miles
has a younger sibling of his own in fact
his sister Nina is the voice of adult
Tim's daughter in the movie indeed you
could say that animation runs in miles
his family because his grandfather is
director Ralph Bakshi whose work
includes the adult animated feature for
it's the cat and the 1978 animated Lord
of the Rings movie as well as the Mighty
Mouse cartoon TV series from the 1980s
and in fact it was ralph bakshi who gave
boss baby director Tom McGrath his first
break back in the early 90s on the movie
cool world Jimmy Kimmel may be best
known for hosting his late-night TV talk
show but it was actually hearing him
being interviewed on the radio that gave
director Tom McGrath the idea of casting
the well-known TV host as Tim's dad in
the movie and Tom McGrath actually has
his own cameo in the movie too as the
voice of the TV chef on the cooking show
that babysitter Eugene watches at Tim's
house by the way if you've watched the
Madagascar movie
used you'll have heard McGrath before as
the voice of the penguin leader skipper
and the movie also keeps things in the
DreamWorks family by casting trolls
director Walt Dohrn as the voice of the
photographer who takes pictures of Tim
and boss baby in their little sailor
outfits now have you seen the boss baby
movie yet and what did you think of it
and what would you like to see happen if
they make a sequel let me know in the
comments below don't forget to subscribe
and comment for your chance to win this
fantastic the art of the boss baby
hardback book if you liked this video
also check out my boss baby Easter eggs
video and my animation playlist here and
remember I always appreciate your likes
shares and comments on my videos thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers